i'm just going to breathe through this
the fact that luca is now dead
he dies as the hero i mean there has
been a massive response online people
fell
blindsided i mean have you seen this
overwhelming response
yeah i mean it's been quite a whirlwind
uh since since last night to this
morning and i've been very taken with
with interviews so i've been largely
sort of missing a lot of what's been
going on
um on social media but uh certainly last
night
um after the airing of it i was flooded
with messages and tweets and
i don't know if i could ever respond to
them all within a lifetime but
i was doing my best to make people feel
seen and heard and and like things and
say thank you and um i i definitely
felt the love last night and it was um
very beautiful
okay so break it down for me because
when you read the script and this is
what was going to happen for deluca
how did you feel about it and did you
know for a while
i did know for a while like sort of
towards the uh beginning of the season
um kind of when we were talking about it
you didn't tell me
oh i couldn't i couldn't tell you we
were so far away
i mean god it was it was easily one of
the hardest secrets i've ever had to
keep
uh apart from maybe like proposing to my
wife i had a ring in my house for like
months that was a pretty hard secret to
keep
but this was like maybe like the second
hardest um yeah
secret to keep for as long as i had to
and
um you know eventually it was you know
my cast members had to become
uh made aware of it and that was a whole
other thing and they were so sad and
shocked and
you know you said the fans felt
blindsided that the cast definitely
felt blindsided um and uh
but no i mean we got an opportunity to
tell a beautiful story
from a character that i am so in love
with and we'll miss dearly
um we got to highlight you know um
his mental illness storyline we got like
human trafficking which is another
pandemic going on in the world
um so it was very grey's anatomy and
sense of you know
highlighting issues we need to see and
talk about but also
um you know paying respect and honor to
this character that's spent so much time
on the show so
um yeah i'm happy it was so well
received
yeah and talk about the respect i mean
i've been sitting with the idea of what
happened last night and it was a
beautiful send-off you're on the beach
where meredith goes when she talks to
people
who are not alive and and deluca says
you'll be okay meredith and that i just
like
you know you lose it at that point and
then lucas mom all of it
what was it like for you to watch that
send off
yeah i mean i've seen it a couple times
uh already because
um i i i just finished directing on the
show and so
you know when you're a director you you
want to come in you want to see
everything that's happened before
yeah i see everything leading up to your
episode that you're going to direct for
context so you know where the story is
at right so
i because of that saw the episode
prior and uh yeah it was an emotional
watch
uh for sure because you know you're
seeing yourself going you're seeing your
character going there's so many
uh complex nuanced emotional
things that are happening within you
that uh that are um
definitely very emotional so um but yeah
it was beautiful i i'm super happy with
with the way it turned out and the
stories were able to tell and
um i got to wrap up all these nice
little pretty bows with like my sister
on the show
uh yeah who i loved dearly we got to
spend some real time together
um and then ellen who has been such an
incredible mentor
ellen pompeo who's been such an
incredible mentor and friend to me over
the years we've gotten much closer
since the writers made us a love
interest on the show we spent even more
time together and so
um i was grateful to the writers for
creating this beach uh because her
character has coven and is largely
unconscious for most of our seasons so
if that wasn't created i really wouldn't
have had any scenes or any any real time
spent with ellen so the fact that i got
this
these couple of days on this beach where
not only i got to act with her and
enjoy that but that you know in between
takes her and i had tons of time to just
sit together on this beach and
talk and reminisce about all our time
together over the years and the show was
beautiful
and a gift and going forward we know
we're gonna have to deal with the
emotions of losing deluca will we get to
see you in some of those scenes again on
the beach or was that the last time we
see you
uh to what i know i think that might be
the last time we see him on the beach
as you know the send-off was so final uh
the other iterations where we can see
deluca through different
flashbacks or people remembering him um
you know
certainly the he's just died you know
what i mean so we're still in in the
shock phase we haven't got to grief we
haven't got to
yes other stages uh
so so um i think in the next couple of
episodes you're gonna see this
kind of shockwave ripple through the
hospital and and and
see how everybody deals with this loss
and how they take it
and there's so much more emotions
involved with because you act did you
get a chance to say
bye to your tv family and say bye to
this character
say bye to meredith does it feel final
for you now
in a very weird serendipitous kind of
way
if i wasn't directing i wouldn't have
been given that opportunity
and so my last days as an actor was not
goodbye
it was see you soon i'm going to be
directing the next couple you know in a
couple episodes
uh so everybody knew i was coming back
and um
you know because of kovid you know we're
largely separated and we don't even uh
meet together
to to do read-throughs of the show
anymore and so if your character doesn't
interact directly
with another actor like you would never
see that actor the
entire season or or year so as a
director
i have to work with every single actor
on the show
and so it was amazing opportunity
coincidentally
for me to just say goodbye and spend
some real time with everybody and
uh it was a beautiful treat and
talking about directing and working with
people i understand there's a little
teaser that
patrick dempsey is back you know
mcdreamy is coming back
i mean can you tell me a little bit
about working with him and what we can
expect going forward
i never got to work with him as he's
always just with uh with ellen on the
beach but
certainly his return has been huge for
the show i mean he's you know
he's he's mcdreamy he's one of the
biggest characters of the show of all
time and so
for the fans having him return has been
has been a huge huge
uh deal um and uh yeah i think it's
something that we're probably going to
continue to
continue to see it and maybe some other
familiar faces who knows
who else hmm any teeth
can you give us any teasers i mean
you're the director essentially you
could tell
anything you have the power i can't
tease about those things but
the beach is definitely something you
know a storytelling device that we're
going to continue to see and we're going
to continue to have
you know old friends stop by and and
and be able to spend time with ellen
because she's largely unconscious
and and you know sleeping so so
um it's it's been it's been a cool
way that we haven't had in other seasons
you know we haven't had this sort of
like
b storyline you know weaving its way
through the entire season where ellen is
in his other place it's been a really
kind of
way to give a fresh look and take on the
show
giacomo your performance when that
intervention happened a few episodes ago
was so powerful i mean that led to so
many people having a conversation and
the importance of mental health
i mean what was the most important
aspect of your character that you just
loved the idea that you were able to
bring forward as a story
hands down um just representation
you know i mean what you were talking
about showing that someone who is
suffering from bipolar
or for that matter any other mental
illness
with uh if you seek help
if you diet and exercise and get rest
and
if a psychiatrist so suggests medication
you can get a better grasp on your life
and it doesn't mean that you're not
going to have bad days
that it's not gonna be hard but that you
will
have a little bit more control over the
demons that
are uh you know inflicting you and and
and
that has been the biggest honor for me
as an actor to portray that
because i i want people to see who are
suffering that they could be in
attending
in a hospital commanding positions below
him
you know balancing a very large budget
being incredibly responsible you know in
a high
high level position i want people in
those positions to think that they can
also attain those goals
in their careers and their lives and
that they're also deserving
and capable of love that's the other big
big thing and i think the if there's a
bittersweet
part of the story it's that you know de
luca
finally getting a grasp on on his demons
and getting his life together
um i i mourn the possibility of
uh his potential that he could have
reached um
as a lover to meredith and and all the
things he could have accomplished in his
career now
um so so that's been the big big honor
and take for me as an actor playing him
are you happy the way he ended for him i
am
i am i think you know his mother's been
mentioned a couple times in the show and
we've
sort of sort of been this ethereal
character that we don't really know so
to see her
i think was kind of a cool easter egg
for the fans and and to see how much she
means to him and that
you know he gets to be reunited with his
mother that he's lost
um and uh and i think having that time
on station 19 where he really spends
time with his sister and the the
audience gets a lot of
time to spend with his childhood and his
backstory
you know furthering his character
development i think it was just a
a very very perfectly written episode
and i'm very grateful to krista
our showrunner and all the yeah she's
involved i think we did
very happy with what we came up with